euromaxx highlights and here's your host
and O'Donnell so welcome to your max
we've selected our highlights for you
let's have a look at some of the
features coming up I opening trip
photographer Ivan bands shot around the
world for an entire year gourmet getaway
we visit the ice q estan way up in the
Austrian Alps and art for art's sake
Elena of cool foster specializes in
combining books with ours the French
city of Lyon was very busy with tourists
again this year the festival of lights
attracted over 4 million visitors for
the four-day event the celebrations
evolved from a religious tradition where
citizens lit candles to mark the
inauguration of a Virgin Mary statue and
the city's hilltop Basilica let's have a
look at the highlights from europe's
biggest light show featuring world-class
artists for four days every year in the
darkness of winter the river streets and
buildings of Leo are turned into a
dazzling festival of lights
excuse me yeah it's great there's so
much to discover only you knew we're
from Leon so we used to it it's always
great festivals great it's our first but
we really love it it allows us to get
some fresh air and see some wonderful
things featuring over 80 light
installations the dazzling display is
the biggest of its kind in europe this
time berlin light designer Christopher
boda is taking part he and his team are
responsible for lighting up the Otay
division the regional government
building as our by the middle east
working with light darkness and light
has always been a fascination of mine
Men's top quality as humans were
conditioned to pay attention to light
and movement and we're all so fascinated
by it and I hope that comes across in
our installation four days before the
festival bouta arrived to begin
programming his spectacle it consists of
50 illuminated triangles suspended above
ground a marriage of motion and music
renowned electronic musician wilbert
hanko worked on the soundtrack I'll be
multi we have light elements that run on
different motors we have 150 individual
motors and 50 light elements that means
everything has to work perfectly a
single fault in the system would cause
big problems was a few streets away
french designer Jean Tschida cast a
magic is testing his installation he's
in charge of lighting Leon's town hall
testp buku burner it's brought me a lot
of joy it's an important project for me
and one that required a lot of
preparation I had to travel to Leon four
or five times luckily I have family here
but I really enjoy the work especially
with so many talented people taking part
in working for the city was yoga DVD the
festival of lights and leo has a long
tradition it started about a hundred and
sixty years ago with a procession of
lanterns and candles in honor of the
Virgin Mary his origins the origins of
the festival make it special it's
anchored deeply in the history of the
city in 1850 to city officials and
religious leaders decided to honor the
Virgin Mary they wanted to erect a
statue of her next to the Basilica it
was supposed to happen on the eighth of
September but the weather was terrible
iconia an ATT break so the people of
Leon decided to push back the date a few
months that's why December the 8th has
since been the day commemorated with a
light procession through the city this
year's event has attracted about 3
million people the highlights include
the projections on the plastic a hole
and an installation in a two kilometer
long highway tunnel
hundreds of visitors have been gathering
to watch Costa Fabares contribution
the installation is working we have met
any big problems so far I think it's
breathtaking skype cast a nutso moment
last night there was a moment when I
stood in front of it and thought is that
that's just incredible it doesn't happen
often with my own work the festival of
lights always finds ways to reimagine
and reinvent itself seeing tradition not
as a constraint but as a strength to
build on in Madrid we went to visit a
very rare publishing house it invites
writers to submit their novels and also
welcome submissions from artists the
business is called ivory press and is
owned by Elena aqua Foster who is an
avid art enthusiast she has managed to
find a way to combine her two passions
and has created a unique artistic theme
that is popular with both artists and
bookworms alike a book made from hand
blown glass that glows from within this
work by artists olafur eliasson is the
latest art book from elena ojo of
fosters publishing house ivory press
here a bronze book cover by anthony caro
encases the hand written poems of german
writer hunts madness in San beggar like
a precious treasure 17 years ago ellen
ochoa foster turned her love of books
into a profession empathy see new moon
tipo de but I found it I've repressed
without having any experience in
publishing whatsoever I simply had a
burning desire to do it and went at it
with real passion I still have this and
hope it will remain so otherwise I'd do
something else it's pretty labor
intensive TC mother while the stars of
the art market clamor to create books
for her the publisher is willing to
indulge their flights of fancy even if
the production costs are exorbitant
ivory press publishes limited editions
that can sell for hundreds of thousands
of euros like wound by an escape or
this video shows how Chinese artists
Angua Chung stages a book burning the
performance is part of his danger book
project urging people to be careful of
books and with books but famous names
alone don't guarantee financial success
yo yo gotti in the beginning I packed my
books in a card and pushed it through
the streets where I could meet
collectors and show them what I was
doing it was incredibly hard dudi sela
it's just as hard now how would I see
you soon though except i'm indy what
they do dope it yet but now I have more
experience and don't make as many of the
mistakes that can ruin not just your
finances but also your morale I llegar a
la arena reliant it because ultimately
you want to be proud of what you do and
get recognition for sake lo que tu haces
estaba conocido today her madrid-based
publishing house employs 17 people it
specializes in coffee table books that
reflect a willingness to experiment even
in mini format
I've repressed now owns a bookstore as
well as an art gallery located in a
former underground parking garage the
gallery was renovated by star architect
Norman Foster Eleanor Cho of fosters
husband of 17 years the couple travels
the world almost always together this is
a person who has extraordinary passion I
mean incredible force and an enthusiasm
and commitment and also very impatient
so things happen quickly but forcefully
but somebody who is also a perfectionist
who has extraordinary standards in the
afternoon Eleanor chua foster plans for
an exhibition with Cuban artists Los
carpintero then she gives some
interviews before attending an art
opening Ellen Ochoa Foster is fully
alert even though she just flew in from
New York at noon they started for the
amiga so I'd rather spend the whole day
at home in my cellar sifting through
pictures or videos with an artist than
lie in the Sun in the Caribbean so I
feel better doing this it's how I earn
my daily bread I need that para Mia's es
mia es me al muerto diario no podria
vivir sin AO
she doesn't just produce artists books
like francis bacon's made to look like
an old suitcase Elena achaia foster also
collects art including this book
sculpture by ansem Kieffer and a whole
room installation from Damien Hirst
they're part of a permanent exhibition
in her gallery which is open to the
public works by South Korean photo
artists bond Chanku which he's currently
showcasing here in Madrid also hang on
her own walls at home Ellen Ochoa Foster
says they give her strength to tackle
new projects and she already has plenty
of those planned for the year ahead
architectural photographer Ivan ban is
making quite the reputation for himself
the Dutchman is regularly published all
over the world and considered one of the
most important architectural
photographers of our time now his latest
installment of work is on display at the
Martin Museum in North rhine-westphalia
Stafford there he's exhibiting 52 weeks
52 cities photographs from his year-long
world trip views of fogo island off
Canada's Atlantic coast and the Chinese
capital Beijing on an unusually clear
day or the capital of allahabad in India
where the Hindu festival Camilla was
celebrated this year there a small taste
of the pictures taken by Dutch
photographer Yvonne bond on his travels
he covered 52 cities in 52 weeks my life
is a non-stop traveling life
I live 365 days a year in hotels out of
suitcases this show is a kind of diary
of the last year of places we've been to
people we've met and things we've seen
the barter Museum and half for Germany
is presenting the first solo exhibition
of the photographers work it encompasses
60 images showing how people live all
over the world even bond gives a glimpse
of many different habitats for the 38
year old the project marks a return to
his artistic roots they came from a
background doing a documentary
photography but there was always
interested in space and people and their
the subjects of my pictures Eurasian
and sort of the architecture happens
sort of in a way anyway in the
background it's the place what sort of
what brings people together so for me
people are in a very important part of
telling these stories and every picture
tells one like this photo taken in the
Nigerian city of Lagos it shows a
floating school by the architect con la
adeyemi it's a pilot project designed to
promote alternative living spaces in a
region prone to flooding Ozma Sega
theaters I really like the fact that
none of the pictures look contrived more
as if they were taken by chance despite
that they're very precise very
expressive he always incorporates people
into his pictures and in doing so
they're very vivid and very personal you
can see how he felt about each different
place it's nice how the emphasis isn't
just on the architecture but also on the
people within the architecture which
isn't often the case with architectural
photography I like that because it's a
different approach Yvonne bond has also
made a name for himself in recent years
as an architectural photographer in May
he shot the new hall at the messe Basel
exhibition centre by the swiss firm l
sog and de Merville
he's also worked for British Iraqi
architect zaha hadid photographing the
library in Vienna that she designed an
art museum in Michigan and a cultural
center in Baku the capital of Azerbaijan
they're all on show in the current
exhibition yesh Takaful Eva Bondoc Damon
Barnes strength is that he completely
dissolves the concept of architectural
photography that means he doesn't
concentrate on iconic buildings but he
focuses on how we human shape living
spaces God with us masters I think
that's what's special about him that he
operates with incredible love of people
places back from kite glide attention to
detail combined with a friendly distance
and a critical eye hands Oxford ending
I'm yet the exhibition and the martyr
museum in Hereford runs until februari
16th meanwhile Yvonne bond continues his
travels a new project takes him to iraq
in a few weeks another destination to be
laid bare by his unique scrutiny
we ate on top of the world in the earth
style valley in southwestern austria
where this week we visited a uniquely
designed restaurant made of glass
structures and situated in the area's
number one mountain for skiing the ice
qrs turant is a transparent structure
and has been ranked as an architectural
masterpiece we couldn't resist its call
of the wild so why don't you join us
smooth surfaces in the jagged and raw
Alpine mountain landscape Ice Cube 3048
meters above sea level it's meant to be
the new attraction in the Austrian Alps
the only day this the basic concept of
the building is about blocks of ice
stacked irregularly on top of each other
than under facets which tablet burn in
ski there are four blocks in all and you
can walk through all of them owned the
elliptic a bobbin we came up with the
idea because we are near the glacier
where it over 3000 meters altitude but I
wasn't meter
the ice cube was built in just six
months from june to november 2013 at a
cost of 4 million euros
it architect has experience with
building in the mountains innsbrook
based johan uber moza three years ago he
and his team built the cable car
stations leading to the summit of the
guys luck Corey that's the mountain
where the ice cube has been built right
next to the summit cross that's
connected by a bridge to the restaurants
rooftop terrace which offers a 360
degree panorama view
florida i think the glass construction
combines well with the snow the ice in
the mountain is correspond yet this
building come we like it we are first
time here and I think it's good that you
prepare this nice place for the tourists
so in that's nice type type it just
shows how much is now being invested in
the comfort of vacationers the view is
amazing especially with this weather
mostly what more could you ask for by
the umbrella hugs of us premiere modern
architecture up in the mountains is
increasingly becoming a major draw for
tourists in 2012 cafe 3440 opened in the
nearby pits Valley and four years ago
the Monte Rosa chalet was built in
Switzerland now with I skew the Earth's
Valley also has a futuristic attraction
flowers as I chose glass as a building
material because it simulates the
transparency of ice blocks we wanted the
greatest possible transparency from
within the Romans to the outside you
don't have to do anything nature brings
it all into the building that was very
important to the concept is what one's
permit wolf surbhi speak so it's easy to
admire the mountain view while staying
elegantly warm and comfortable for
instance in the 80 square metre lounge
but the heart of the building is the
designer restaurant on the second floor
head chef haha bundler is from South
book he offers daily specials for up to
80 euros but also a la carte options all
with a sophisticated culinary approach
hunter wants his cuisine to be every bit
as special as the view of the mountain
top part of the marketing concept
includes an exclusive wine selection
three top vilnius from germany austria
and italy have created a red wine
especially for I skew the Pinot 3000
it'll soon be aged here in oak barrels
rather than only in the bottle
the quantities the idea is to bring the
barrels from the individual vineyards up
here then store the wine under these
very special high-altitude conditions
the temperature is a constant 12 degrees
Celsius but due to the difference in air
pressure the wine will mature more
slowly in the oak barrels ode cuisine
and futuristic design the idea behind
Ice Cube's Odin is drawing plenty of
visitors an elegant restaurant high on
the guys like Olga is indeed a heady
combination well if you're a bit of a
Scrooge saying Christmas is no fun
festive traditions are impossible to
escape this month here in Germany every
corner you turn there's a mulled wine
stand talk of Santa Claus not to mention
the Christmas markets all these typical
Christmas traditions and it's certainly
put Scrooge's head in a spin cloudy a
vine Gartner however was wondering where
all of these practices came from she's
written a book about us and we went to
meet her at the Munich christmas market
for the Lord n gingerbread christmas
trees Santa Claus and a post office for
wish lists these are all staples of a
typical German Christmas market but
where do these traditions come from
Claudia vine Gartner is asking precisely
that question her new book Alice mitosis
or it's all a myth looks at the origins
of German and European Christmas
traditions
question one this one's for the kids
where does Santa Claus come from these
youngsters agree definitely the North
Pole well I know the red clothes were
definitely brought in by coca-cola it's
true that a coca-cola advertising
campaign in the 1930s popularized the
image of the plump bearded Santa Claus
we know today as for his hometown many
people say that's rovaniemi in Lapland
the city then officially registered
itself as the home of Santa Claus in the
European Union
diviner someone bought it off kind Santa
Claus definitely wasn't created by
coca-cola and he doesn't come from a
North Pole either he's a relation of
cynical asst who became part of a Dutch
tradition that was taken on by America
when people emigrated there and from
there they just spread question 2 is
Christmas really a celebration of love
it's a celebration of love but it's
stressful it's stressful at first but
then it's a celebration of love vista
libre according to a study twenty one
percent of germans argue at Christmas
major causes of strife include
decorations who's doing all the work or
even where to spend the holidays but
there is some truth to the idea that
love is an important part of the holiday
the 91 @ nuff by nine months after
Christmas more babies are born and in
any other month so there must be
something in the claim that Christmas is
a celebration of love question 3 does
Christmas make us fat occupy my final
you definitely get fat at Christmas the
food we eat has so many rich ingredients
nutritionists agree that the unsaturated
fats and Christmas treats are unhealthy
but it seems most people don't go too
over-the-top on sweets at Christmas time
by not math mystic the Christmas doesn't
make you fat according to a British
study which says men and women only put
on about 400 grams other than that
Christmas treats are healthy ingredients
like whole grain wheat flour almonds and
nuts are packed with energy and they
also help soothe the nerves when it
comes to gifts the cliche state that
women like jewelry and men like gadgets
but what did German men and women really
want scooter in the camera jewelry a
track vehicle a PlayStation 4 according
to a consumer survey German spent 290
euros per year on Christmas gifts on
average but toys jewelry and gizmos
aren't the most popular present
but in getting with Christmas presents a
good old-fashioned book is often under
the tree for most Germans it doesn't
always have to be jewelry for women and
gadgets for men techniques to snug fit
in month I'll question 5 y de Germans
always give presents on the
twenty-fourth of December well for the
future says to price wasn't even born
yet but so what don't know most European
countries give presents on the
twenty-fifth of December but the Germans
just can't wait that extra day unless
wise keine van Jesus no one knows when
Jesus was born but at some point the
church set the date as December the 25th
but in Germany people used to spend the
time before going to church in the pub
as a result the church services were a
bit to marry for the church's liking so
they brought the services forward in
some places always guard munch odds then
gotta since father league and that's why
father Christmas will make his
deliveries in Germany on the
twenty-fourth of December as usual well
that's it from me an O'Donnell and the
rest of the air max crew thanks for
watching and don't forget you can check
out our highlight features online thanks
for watching
by travelpod member